Tyrod Taylor went from 4-year backup
with the Ravens who never played because
Joe Flacco was able to play all the
games those four seasons and then Tyrod
Taylor becomes the starter in Buffalo
and then gets traded after taking the
bills to the postseason to the Browns
and he started a few games got injured
Baker Mayfield starts playing then Tyrod
Taylor becomes journeyman a backup
backed up Mayfield the rest of 2018
backed up Philip Rivers last year but
now Taylor the guy who by all
appearances is penciled in as the number
one guy in the Chargers depth chart
he told Tyler Dunn of bleacher report
all I can do is show him with the next
opportunity they shouldn't have slept on
me I'm definitely motivated more than
ever I'm motivated because I'm able to
show my teammates and my coaches what
I'm capable of doing Peter look if the
Chargers could bring in Cam Newton right
now and give him a full and complete
physical and check out his foot and his
ankle and his shoulder would they do
that would they kick the tires and
thoroughly explore the the health of Cam
Newton with the idea of maybe making him
the guy if everything checked out
probably Mike probably but not certainly
and I think one of the reasons is that
Anthony Lin in this odd year okay
Anthony Lin really I mean one of the
favorite players one of his favorite
players on the team is Tyrod Taylor been
an excellent soldier has been a great
team guy really helped Philip Rivers and
and was a good you know team backup guy
okay and I think he believes that Tyrod
Taylor based on what he saw in Buffalo
in that playoff season and based on the
kind of guy he's been with this team
which is kind of sort of what Teddy
Bridgewater was in New Orleans I think
he he wants to give Tyrod Taylor this
shot and I'm not saying it's forever and
you make a very interesting point if
they could have a blank slate with a Cam
Newton and they could do it right now
would they do it they might but I don't
think it's certain just because of the
way Anthony Lin feels about tie-rod
and I keep coming back to my belief that
the Chargers need to embrace the fact
that they are in LA and I understand
that they think they're going to draw in
fans if they win games and even the
concept of drawing in fans seems alien
right now because of the reality that
we're inhabitant the idea of getting
people to follow the team watch them on
TV buy the jerseys Cam Newton is a guy
that can do it and even if they go 12
and 4 with Tyrod Taylor I don't think
that's enough to win the battle in LA
and and maybe the disintegration of the
Rams is the best thing that's happening
to the Chargers maybe by default if the
Chargers couldn't win they'll start
converting some fans but to me it makes
it even more sensible to pursue a Cam
Newton if they can come to the point
where they're they're confident that
he's going to be healthy and able to
contribute but you know I and I don't
want to downplay Tyrod Taylor's
abilities he has shown he can win Peter
I just don't know how far he can take a
team we've seen Cam Newton take a team
to a Super Bowl it's right Mike and you
just the reason the only reason that I
put the asterisk on that and I say
probably they would do a deep dive into
Cam Newton it's because look go back to
when I talked to him late last July
early August in training camp in
Spartanburg South Carolina he talked
openly to me about being a different
quarterback and he liked the fact that
as he got into his 30s that he has seen
guys like Peyton Manning and and other
older quarterbacks adjusting their games
and so he was looking forward to that
and that's why because you really don't
know what Cam Newton is going to be as a
player is he going to be that guy who
was the MVP cam he's gonna run around
and and and who's gonna risk getting hit
a lot or does he want to stay in the
pocket more and those are the kind of
things unless you do that deep dive you
just don't know
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports